And last but not least in this final installment of Collab Week,
I am joined by the superlative adjective Tomska,
and we will be collaborating through the medium of song.
TOM: I would love to write a song about Google Plus,
but a song about how we like Google Plus.
CHARLIE: That's not bad. I like the idea that we would write a song
positively about Google Plus, but we would just be--
we can make the subtext of the song of doing it begrudgingly.
TOM: Because we have to. Yeah.
I thought we could use quite a fast and happy song.
This is quite sad. Google Plus...why?
[GUITAR PLAYING] Yeah like that.
CHARLIE: Writing a song, sometimes that takes all day.
How long have we got now? 40 minutes.
TOM: I need you to know that this is the first time I've ever tried to write a song.
CHARLIE: Okay, that's fine.
TOM: So we're off to a good start.
So all the metaphors that I can come up with is like
Google being the guy at the party who keeps like changing the song,
but it's Google's party so we kind of have to just do it any way.
What was that like do doo da do doo do doo do.
♪Google Plus. Something, something, something, something.
CHARLIE: That may be the song.
TOM: Something, something, something, something. Something fuss?
CHARLIE: ♪Google Plus. TOM: ♪Something, something, something, something such a fuss.
No that's a start. Maybe we should mention Emma Blackery in this song?
CHARLIE: Yeah. ♪Sorry Emma Blackery made such a fuss.
Alright, that's our first complete line.
TOM: Okay. Google Plus. Sorry Emma Blackery made such a fuss.
So we now need to do another "us" thing.
This is Charlie's channel so we just can't fuss? We just can't cuss?
CHARLIE: ♪We promise Tom and Charlie...something we won't cuss.
TOM: ♪We promise Tom and Charlie will try not to cuss.
CHARLIE: Yeah, okay. Da da da da da da da da.
Da da da da da da da da doo. That's how it changes.
TOM: ♪We didn't ask for it but got it anyway.
♪Like or not...the site is here to stay.
CHARLIE: Yep that's it. Write it.
TOM: Yeah? Yeah, I mean I did don't worry. This a pre-written line.
CHARLIE: ♪Now it seems like Google Plus is here to stay.
TOM: Hey, I like it.
TOGETHER: ♪Google Plus. TOM: Okay. Yeah. So we'll come back in with "Google Plus."
Aw fu-- we're going to have to rhyme "plus" again though.
Like maybe then we like change the other pronunciation to like "Google Positive."
CHARLIE: ♪Google Add. TOM: ♪We'll promise that this site is really not too bad.
CHARLIE: There we go! Write it down.
TOM: When we ask for a plus one please try to not get mad? or something.
CHARLIE: Yeah. Maybe we could say if one of the features is rad.
TOM: Add me in your circle it's so totally...it's so kind of rad.
CHARLIE: ♪Add me in your circle so I won't be sad
TOM: Yeah? CHARLIE Yeah.
TOM: I really want to get some of the metaphors, though,
of like Google Plus being a guy at a party.
♪Have you ever been to a party and the host keeps changing the song?
♪But the party's in his house so you just kind of play along.
CHARLIE: Kind of dance along maybe.
TOGETHER: ♪We promise that this site is really not too bad.
CHARLIE: ♪Add us in your circle so we won't be sad.
We still haven't done anything about like "give us a plus one."
♪If you're feeling good give us plus one
TOM: ♪So that I don't start running out of funds.
Please like me on Google Plus 'cause otherwise I'm going to run out of money.
I don't know if that's a message I really want to be sending in this song.
CHARLIE: But it does rhyme.
TOM: It does rhyme. Like Robin Thicke didn't want to be really rapey, but it did rhyme.
CHARLIE: ♪Help us out and give us your plus ones.
And know that we'll appreciate them tons. TOM: Yes! Yes.
CHARLIE: ♪Have you ever been to a party
♪where the host keeps changing the song
♪but when the party's hosted by Google, we'd better keep dancing along
TOM: Ha ha ha ha. Yeah that's fine.
CHARLIE: Shall I write them down in order?
TOM: Yeah. Maybe we need to type them out.
CHARLIE (mumbling): Emma Blackery...Blackering...made such a fuss
And here we go.
♪GUITAR♪
TOGETHER: ♪Google Plus
♪Sorry Emma Blackery made such a fuss
♪We promise Tom and Charlie will try not to cuss.
♪We didn't ask for it but got it anyway.
♪So now it's seems like Google Plus is here to stay. (TOM: It is.)
TOGETHER: ♪Google Add.
♪We promise that this site is really not too bad
♪Add us in your circle so we won't be sad
♪Help us out and give us your plus ones
♪And know we will appreciate them tons
♪Have you ever been to a party
♪And the host keeps changing the song,
♪But when the party's hosted by Google
♪You better keep dancing along
♪Google Plus
♪Something, something, something, something Google Plus...
TOM: Hm... CHARLIE: That'll do. Collab week.
TOM: Collab week. CHARLIE: Woo!
TOM: I'm out.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Okie Dokie, thank you very much for watching collab week,
and if you didn't watch collab week,
here are all the videos that you missed.
And that's all. Ta-ra! Ta-ra is British for "goodbye" just FYI
SILENCE